this Friday we'll get ready for the
return of shaft but samuel l.jackson
Richard Roundtree and a hot young
newcomer okay hold on wait a minute I'd
say what's going on you bring me in here
so Kevin can be the only one who gets to
go to the set about getting shafted
I like how they look at you first of all
like this is what I walk on set
three generations of shaft in one movie
at the youngest Jesse T usher still has
a lot to learn your kid is this super
nerdy computer kind of he's an IT dude
so we have to teach him how to be a [ __ ]
I'm the furthest thing from a shaft that
a shaft has ever been you just break
laws you committed human rights
violations sounds ex and Jesse's mom is
Regina Hall and let's face it the exes
welt' they don't get along where there's
love and passion you know it can be
volatile but there is a lot of love for
Richard Leo original shaft best thing
about shaft you got right he's cool I'll
take that all right now what about this
young shaft jury's still out
[Music]
[Applause]